so
i'm actually giving my talk on my
surface not because i want to increase
the
number of windows users from four to
five in the room
or to see if it works on an incline
which it does
for now thankfully there's a lip here at
the end but because i think it really
represents
a new class of machines that we need to
think about as web developers
whoops hopefully
oh come on
okay
oh i'm gonna restart though
here's my demo for later um
and the reason that it it really
represents a new class of machines
is that the the web and unless you've
been trapped underneath the rock you
know the web has
mobile web has been great you know
increasing really really rapidly um
so sorry hang on
okay let's try this again
yay okay so as you know thank you
i knew it was a huge risk using the
surface i'm gonna push out anyway
um so as you know unless you've been
trapped underneath a rock the
usage of the mobile web is increasing at
a phenomenal rate
right that's that shouldn't be a
surprise to anybody if you were
underneath the rock you know
welcome back um other news the berlin
wall has fallen
but what really compounds this and the
reason that i brought the surface up is
that
it's not only it's not only mobile
devices that are getting touched but
also desktop devices
and the surface is emblematic of that
um but what that really means is that in
as we think about our our websites is
that
touch is really going forward going to
be the predominant way that people use
um uh the web i'm gonna pick on
um so some of the research we've done as
part of the surface
is um there's you know obviously
patterns that don't work with the web or
with the touchable web
and one i'm going to pick on is the
hover um uh obviously hover does not
work with touch of lab there's no
state when you're using your finger um
where
you're not you know you're not you're
kind of over it but but not on it
and i'm going to pick on that but
there's a number of other ui techniques
like that
in our research we found that um over 65
percent of websites were using
some mechanism like this that made it
very difficult to use
at a very high level ui technique to use
the touchable web
um so my ask is that if you're one of
those 65 have a look at your website and
make sure you're not you're not breaking
the touchable web
the second thing i want to think of
wanted you to think about is that
the touchable web means that you need to
think about the size of your touch
targets
and as part of doing the surface we did
a lot of research around what's the
optimal size of touch
targets and we did that we measured
people's fingers we found that
that that kids when they first are able
to use a touchable web they have
roughly eight millimeter fingers up to
the largest um
adult has you know roughly a 19
millimeter
finger with kind of an 11 millimeter
average
um and we use that to do research on
what the smallest
target size or kind of the optimal
target size you should use
um and so we ran a bunch of experiments
um changing the size of the touch target
um
over a range of different values and
what we found is that
as you went below five millimeters
asymptotically
the error rate at which they you know
the error rate they had
trying to complete that task went up
asymptotically
and it's compounded by the fact that
they spent asymptotically more time
trying to select that that particular
touch target
so what our research showed was that
somewhere between seven and nine
millimeters for a touch target is kind
of the
kind of the sweet spot and on screen
that works out to something like 40 to
50 pixels
85 percent of sites that we looked at
had some some page that violated
this this rule and made it hard for
touch users to use so if you're one of
you know if you're
building a an application that you want
used on
um on devices with touch i encourage you
to look to make sure that you're not one
of these 85 percent
another thing we did is we looked at
kind of a heat map of where is easy for
people to
to to reach on there on their mobile
device um and this is an example we use
for the surface
um the green areas show the areas that
are very easy to reach uh for
uh the the 90 percentile of users um the
red areas are the
the the people with the biggest hands
and then kind of the 10
tile um and what's obvious from this is
that
the middle right and left are the
easiest places for people to
to to you know to hit touch targets they
have the most accuracy
they're the most you know ergonomically
correct um and so as you're thinking
about this and what we do at microsoft
is as we the guidance we give our
designers is
essentially that that the the band that
runs kind of in a u
from the left and the right middle down
through the bottom and back up
are the best places to have your
interaction area and on the phone
probably makes a lot of intuitive sense
kind of in the middle of the screen are
the best places to have your touch
targets
it's kind of the opposite for where you
want people to be able to read
so in terms of reading areas
the places where the hands are not
obscuring the screen
you know work out to be the the best
places to have to have touch targets
that's probably not not very surprising
um
any of us in this room um the other
thing i wanted
to mention is uh
good okay is that people come from
native applications to the
to the you know the touchable web a lot
of expectations
um so they they expect to be able to use
multi
uh multi-point gestures in order to
control the web and a lot of
browsers have implemented that natively
to kind of keep up with that expectation
but obviously building an application
like this
within the browser is is something
that's been beyond us
and so as angelina said we've been
working with the w3c
and um it's not just us it's it's
mozilla we jointly proposed this with
mozilla
and a lot of thanks to them um to bring
a unified model for these these pointer
devices that are beyond the mouse
we've been using you know essentially a
mouse event model
uh for the last 15 odd years that really
assumes that there's only a there's only
a mouse attached to the computer
we need we need to improve on that um
and it's moved from a first public
working draft to a candidate
recommendation
um in roughly five months which we think
you know uh
demonstrates there's a lot of a lot of
momentum and recognition that this is a
real a real problem um and so i'm going
to spend the rest of the
kind of presentation working through
what that means and essentially
the the top level uh you know way to
think about this
is it's an evolution of of mouse events
um
to be more general uses the same event
model
more or less you can drop in pointer
events for mouse events and your
applications just still work the same
we have added one event a pointer cancel
event
which is primarily used for when there's
an orientation change and it
it makes sense to not process the
the the maybe some some previous touch
events that have occurred
um but otherwise it's very similar what
has changed is that we've added a number
of attributes to provide a richer model
for handling handling pointer events
but your existing button client x client
y those attributes remain the same have
the same semantics
that are still available to you as web
developers
um and so working through them one by
one uh
width and height provides you with
the ability to have the you know or the
recognition that in the real world
many pointing devices have a real
physical size and kind of the the
canonical example of that is your finger
um your finger can have a small amount
of of contact area
if you're using your fingernail um and
obviously a larger one if you're
you're pushing down very hard and so
this is passed through in terms of in a
bounding box
um around the client x and client y that
gives you some indication of how much of
the
um the pointing pointer device is in is
intersecting with the screen
and this obviously and you'll see this
later um
is is you know a good way of doing
things like finger painting applications
where you want to have that richness of
of taking advantage of that in that
intersection with the screen
there's also the concept of pressure uh
for screens that support it
um and tilt x and tilt y
um pressure is what you'd expect if the
digitizer surface or screen
supports it it gives you an indication
of how much pressure is being applied to
the screen
tilt tilt x and tilt y um are you know
probably
you know the canonical example there is
a pen where you might want to have a
different effect on the screen depending
on the tilt you know
perhaps apply a sonography kind of
different line style or whatnot to match
up with the user's expectation
these two provide uh
you know the ability to under you know
understand more or to handle
separate uh so point of type
gives you the ability to handle um
pointer devices differently in general
you're going to want to handle them the
same
but pointer type allows you to handle
you know for instance a pen device
differently from a mouse device
in you know situations where that's
important and then pointer id
is kind of a new concept because there
can be multiple streams of pointer
events if you think about if you have
two or three fingers on the screen at
once
those are actually all separate pointer
devices
um in terms in terms of this event model
and so
pointer id allows you to disambiguate
all those different event streams so
that you can handle them
in the way that makes the most sense for
your application
all right so i'm going to switch over
and do a demo
all right great and so
the demo i'm going to do is really
simple finger painting application
not sure how visible that is it's fairly
visible and basically i have a canvas
i've added some pointer events here
added them as event listeners i'm using
in navigator there's pointer enabled
which tells you if this if player
pointer events are possible in your
browser there's two types of that
um in ie10 we actually have the vendor
prefix version
and then as as browsers adopt this
there'll be a non-prefix version called
pointer enabled
and then from there every time we get an
event uh when we start painting
i'm going to maintain a list of
essentially four points um
and then as we get individual pain
events i am going to just do a curve
between all those those points that
we've built up
and and finally as we're doing multiple
these we'll i'll shift them off the end
and add the new one to it so it's pretty
straightforward
i'll show you what that looks like um
i just thought of a problem okay uh so
when you know the mouse this work this
works perfectly
um unfortunately i didn't i didn't think
about this
problem but when you touch it
it also has this the problem i have is
that because i'm displaying on the
screen i can't touch this screen
but imagine that was a touch uh
let's see okay so the problem we have
there
is that we're not using so if we look
back at this code we're not using
um we're not using the pointer id to
actually
um to actually disambiguate a different
stream so if i had to use multi-touch
there
it would it would have done back and
forth across the to the different
streams of events that
uh were you know were being received by
the browser
and so to disambiguate that uh
in this in this example i'm using a
pointer id to eventually
to basically build up separate sets of
of of content
um and so when we draw the lines they'll
be separate lists
and it and it'll and it'll display as
you'd expect
um
and so doing two at the same time you
know essentially it uses a separate
uh separate streams list to display it
the final thing
you notice there is i'm not using any
concept of the width uh
to display or sorry the width and the
height that's passed through as part of
the pointer event
to display a different width and height
to the line
and we can do that with um event.width
and event.height
uh and essentially use that to drive the
the width that we're using for the
uh the line that's displayed um and
and and if we do that
that's hard to do with my finger we get
slightly bigger widths than what it
works better if it's on the actual
screen but um
what you'll see is it it'll it'll depend
on if you're using your your
uh with a higher quality digitizer
you'll see that
that it decreases and decreases your
bite with your
your finger so that's that's a brief
example of how you use it
natively um
uh i just want to talk a little bit how
you get started um so ie10 has
vendor prefix support for this um this
is in without vendor prefixes in ie11
um our opentech teams opentech inside
microsoft is a team of folks that
contribute to open source projects
and they've done a webkit prototype of
this
it's available here i believe they
also are have announced an intent to
implement for the blink project as well
as a formal implementation but if you
really want to get started today there's
a couple of polyfills that are available
hand.js was developed by a person at
microsoft
and then there's also points.js which is
developed by richard harris so
that's kind of a quick overview of
pointer events
i am around the rest of the day if you
have any more questions
but thank you
i already see a question in the audience
so let's kick this off here
hey so um to kind of stress what dominic
nicola told about
told us about uh forcing vendors to
expose
richer functionality pointer events are
great in the sense of
obstructing mouse and touch events what
about gestures
is there anything sure there's there's
not anything i i
really encourage people look to that
spec there's not anything in this
specification about gestures themselves
um it's just this event model but it it
does make a ton of sense to
to start building on top of that for
yeah because i think
most gestures are becoming kind of
popular exactly
so yeah it makes total sense yeah thanks
yeah
other questions okay one over there
um one question about interpreted
movements of
like where you have a pre-assumption of
what the user wants to achieve like a
scroll which is essentially a touch
on on mobile devices yep uh is anything
in this back there that makes that
easier if you want to do like
headers that like retract or something
no there's nothing in the spec about
that this is purely for
um the the content region of the of the
web page
yeah okay
i think that's it i don't see any more
hands oh wait one more hold on
really quick okay so
that uh i'm interested the the five
millimeter 50 pixel thing yeah i'm glad
you're pointing that out that's great
because i've always wondered what the
sweet spot is uh but does that imply
anything about text size for like links
you know intertextual links um that
research
mostly did um mostly looked at the size
in terms of simply clicking it um if you
hit me on twitter that's my twitter
address
i will i'll find out if we did research
around the text size yeah
thanks awesome thank you very much tim
yeah thanks for having me